ja sind ja wirklich bittere Geschichten
die wir da aus Mecklenburg-Vorpommern im
Moment hören 20 Millionen aus dem Kreml
vermeintlich für den Klimaschutz dann
eine
Finanzbeamtin die aus Panik vor der
Politik eine brisante Steuererklärung im
Kamin einer bekannten verbrennt ein
Finanzminister der dazu das Parlament
belügt und eine Ministerpräsidentin die
von all dem dann erst aus der Presse
erfahren haben will ich weiß das klingt
irgendwie nach der Beschreibung von
einem Lauenen Sonntag abend Krimi das
Problem ist aber der Tatort Schwerin
metaphorisch garniert mit Liebesgrüßen
aus Moskau das war leider die Realität
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und diese
Vorgänge werden im Moment von Manuela
Schwesig nicht aufgearbeitet sondern
Kamin Gates wird zum handfesten Problem
für die Landesregierung täuschen und
verdecken das ist im Moment das Thema
und das ist eine schwere schwere
Belastung für die Landesregierung und
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern wird vor manchem
jetzt schon hier mit einer Verwaltung in
einer Bananenrepublik verglichen das tut
mir vor allem für die fleißigen Beamten
in unserem Land Leid und das muss
personelle Konsequenzen haben das heißt
sie würden so weit gehen den Rücktritt
von der Manuela Schwesig zu fordern sie
muss zumindest jetzt erstmal in ihrer
eigenen Landesregierung da aufräumen
also ich finde es ist ein unhaltbarer
Zustand wenn man sich vor Augen führt
dass in diesen Fragen gelogen wird dass
der Finanzminister des Landes da das
Parlament belogen hat das ist ein
schwerer Vorwurf und auch Manuela
Schwesig hat er noch eine Reihe von
ungeklärten Fragen und da brauchte es
jetzt nicht zartes weglächeln wir haben
ja gestern im Bundestag darüber
diskutiert die Ministerpräsidentin hätte
reden können sie ist nicht in den
Bundestag gekommen jetzt gibt es dann
morgen eine Sondersitzung in Schwerin im
Landtag wo klar Fragen in den
Ausschüssen gestellt werden und ich
glaube jedenfalls es schadet dem
angesprochenen Vertrauen in die Politik
eben noch mehr und ganz massiv wenn
diese Themen jetzt nicht aufgearbeitet
werden und das braucht er auch
Konsequenzen und da muss Schwesig jetzt
eine Antwort geben einmal Klartext haben
Sie den Eindruck dass er eigentlich eine
Landesregierung mehr oder weniger für
den Kreml gearbeitet hat und sich daran
dann auch noch bereichert hat kann man
so zusammenfassen das ist vielleicht
eine etwas pointierte Zusammenfassung
und zur Wahrheit gehört auch das will
ich ja auch sagen als damals zum
damaligen Zeitpunkt diese Klima
Stiftungen Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
gegründet wurde da haben wir in der CDU
ja auch mitregiert und uns wurde immer
gesagt na ja der Fertigbau von Nord
Stream 2 das war zum damaligen Zeitpunkt
ja auch ein politisches Interesse auch
in der Bundespolitik aber das
eigentliche Problem jetzt sind ja die
Folge Fragen im Umgang daraus die sich
ergeben haben wieso findet man das
eigentlich normal dass dann vor
irgendwie etlichen Monaten von einem
Dreivierteljahr also diese brisante
Steuererklärung verbrannt wird wieso
informiert man dann darüber nicht und
der Angst Vorgänger von Manuela schwer
sich der Erwin Sellerie sind
abenteuerliche Geschichte dann Frau
Schwesig hätte Abend gegessen mit dem
Chef von Nord Stream 2 und ihm dann
irgendwelche Zusagen zur
Gemeinnützigkeit der Stiftung gemacht
und das sind doch alles es wird stände
es wird offenbar blockiert es wird
offenbar auch Unterlagen werden offenbar
vernichtet hat Fassbender was sagt so
ein Beispiel der Tatort Schwerin hatte
das jetzt gerade über den Zustand der
Politik auch um die Ohren geflogen
erinnern wir uns zurück wo die Stiftung
wurde ja ursprünglich bin kein Klima
stiftungsexperte ja aber die Stiftung
wurde ja gegründet weil es die Gefahr
gab dass das Ganze Nord Stream zwei
Projekt unter US-amerikanische sekundär
Sanktion viel und um dieses Projekt zu
retten hat man das äh in Staatsnähe
rücken wollen ja aus der freien aus der
Wirtschaft heraus und hat sich dieses
stiftungskonstrukt da überlegt also ich
erinnere mich noch
2020/21 als ich das erste Mal hörte von
dieser Stiftung da hatte ich schon
wohliges Gefühl in dem Sinne also da
haben sich ja russische Berater damit
geschrieben weil das klingt das klingt
so nach nach so einem das war ein Trick
ja und der Trick ist uns jetzt mit dem
Krieg und mit mit dem Ende von
nordstream 1 und 2 dick um die Ohren
geflogen und jetzt geht es darum wie
kommt und deswegen haben auch beide
Parteien daran mitgearbeitet weil es gab
schon Ziel damals ja ist uns um die
Ohren geflogen und jetzt kommt kommt
darauf an wie man für die Politik und
für das Politik Vertrauen so sauber wie
möglich aus der Sache wieder rauskommt
wenn die Frau Schwesig drüber
zurücktreten muss muss sie zurücktreten
im Moment ist man ja nicht unbedingt auf
dem besten Wege da sauber rauszukommen
die Verflechtung die Nähe zwischen
Wirtschaft und Politik eine zu große
Nähe ist sie aus ihren Augen überhaupt
vermeidbar kann man das irgendwie oder
läufst irgendwie am Ende immer so ich
halte die Nähe schon für wichtig dafür
sind beide Themen Politik und Wirtschaft
weil für sehr wichtig ich sag mal immer
so gefährlich wird es immer
geht ja noch ein bisschen von dem Thema
dann ab der Staat setzt sozusagen die
Leitplanken ja und und ist sage ich mal
wenn wir jetzt mal Sport sind eine Art
Schiedsrichter ja aber er sollte dann
eben wenn es dann um das eigentlich zu
dir geht nicht mitspielen und da hat man
eben so wenn man das ein bisschen
betrachtet jetzt mittlerweile das Gefühl
dass der Staat ja immer mehr Aufgaben an
sich zieht und eben praktisch immer mehr
zum Schiedsrichter und Spieler wird Frau
Engelmeier Abpfiff für Frau Schwesig
wird das diskutiert in der SPD das weiß
ich nicht ich bin ja wenn sie dafür tief
nein weil ich setzt da tiefes Vertrauen
auch in die Landesregierung
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern das wird
aufgearbeitet und sagen war doch mal so
ja antworten im schlimmsten Falle
informiert keinen einziger Ministeriums
Mitarbeiter dann braucht sie sich wenn
er irgendwas was nicht in Ordnung ist in
seinem Kamin verbrennt das glaube ich
schon das ist easy irgendwann erreicht
hat und das wird aufgearbeitet ich finde
immer diese Rücktrittsforderung die
finde ich schon sehr sehr schwierig ich
finde Manuela sich und die ähm
Landesregierung machen eine gute Arbeit
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ja und wir
warten mal ab das Nord Stream 2 so
richtig schief gegangen ist das haben
sie auch gerade gut gesagt ich erinnere
mich auch an die Fotos wo man das
abgefeiert hat wo CDU aber SPD zusammen
war und ich glaube lassen wir sie doch
ihre Arbeit machen aber fehlt nicht auch
eine gewisse rücktrittskultur gerade in
der Politik beispielsweise in
Griechenland da musst du jetzt der
Verkehrsminister nach einem riesigen
Zugunglück zurücktreten man sieht seine
Konsequenzen einfach und jetzt sehen wir
da es werden Unterlagen vernichtet es
werden die Aufarbeitung ein bisschen
blockiert also wann ist der Punkt
gekommen dass man auch sagen muss daraus
ziehe ich auch meine persönlichen
Konsequenzen weil sie Verantwortung
trage wo sehen sie da den Punkt wo sehe
ich den Punkt ich sage ja ich ich habe
mich mit der Sache so noch nicht
beschäftigt ich hätte mir vorstellen
können und ich will ja gar kein Fass
aufmachen aber in der corona-pandemie da
gab es auch das eine oder andere ich
will einfach mal nur an Masken Deals und
der Archiven erinnern da hätte ich mir
auch vorstellen können dass der eine
oder andere Minister vielleicht gesagt
hätte okay das ist jetzt so ist auch
nicht passiert deswegen lassen wir sie
doch ihre Arbeit machen und wie können
wir darüber sprechen
toll viele sprechen auch noch darüber ob
genau das passiert ich
persönlich Michaela Engelmeier nee das
war nicht Karl Lauterbach zu der Zeit
mit diesem ganzen Thema Masken Deals
hatte ich entspannt a nichts zu tun und
B die die das betraf die sind damals bei
uns aus der Fraktion geflogen und
zurückgetreten so ich finde jetzt ist
halt eine Grenze erreicht wenn man wenn
man sieht bei diesem Thema der
Diskussionen Schwerin wenn man sich das
anguckt wenn dann ein Minister wirklich
wissentlich das Parlament belügt wenn
gefragt wird gibt es Erkenntnisse zu
verloren gegangenen Steuererklärung und
jetzt muss er zugestehen paar Wochen
vorher ist sie mitgeteilt worden die
sind Kamin verbrannt worden wenn er dann
sagt ja nein ich wusste nichts das ist
etwas wo eine Grenze überschritten ist
und das eine ist immer einen Fehler zu
machen wie auch den Fehler und zwei und
die Frage ist aber wie geht man dann
damit um und Frau Schwesig hat dann
direkt nach dem russischen Angriffskrieg
gesagt gut wir ziehen die Konsequenzen
und hat dann sich groß Asche über das
Haupt gestreut und hat aber bereits im
März
25 vor einem Jahr hat sie gesagt die
Stiftung soll aufgelöst werden passiert
es bis heute nicht sie hat gesagt die 20
Millionen die an Geld vom Kreml kam die
sollen jetzt der Ukraine zur Verfügung
gestellt werden passiert ist nichts und
da sind dann irgendwann Punkte erreicht
wenn man dann sagt man will eine große
Aufarbeitung machen und die bleibt dann
aus dann ist es schon etwas was massiv
gerade wie groß ist da der Frust der
Bürger Herr Faßbender das niemand
zurücktritt und Verantwortung schon
wachsen dieser Frust denn menschlich
gesehen ist es ja so die Klima Stiftung
war eine gute Idee unter dem
mottofrecher siegt nur hat die Frechheit
nicht gesiegt ja und dann muss einer
verantworten ja es passiert auch mal
Pech und dann kann auch eine Frau
Schwesig einfach mal Pech haben weil sie
letzten Endes in der Verantwortung steht
für diese für die Frechheit die nicht
gesiegt hat und äh ich glaube das wäre
schon befreiende Signal wenn wenn wenn
sie zurücktrete und sagt es ist nun mal
so ja man kann man es ist man ist als
ministerieller Verantwortung oder als
Mini Minister oder Premierminister oder
Politiker in Europa hohenstellung auch
verantwortlich für Taten von
Untergebenen oder Sachen die getan
werden an denen man selber gar nicht
schuldig unmittelbar beteiligt ist
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt das
ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie